hey guys Ryan right here Jerry here Dan
zapper
we're gonna watch the trailer for su two
trailers for Super Smash Brothers on the
Wii U mmm
there we go doubled trailer meltdown I
love Super Smash Bros remember that
first came out on n64 holy [ __ ]
that was amazing dude do you remember
that no it's like that was the game you
played with you remember hearing about
it and then you play it I was like wow
and that melee came out was the vaginas
everywhere they almost didn't do Smash
Bros really yeah originally it was on
the cutting board but they pushed it
through and end up being like one of the
most successful things I have oh cool
fun fact check that fact before you post
that in no I'm gonna post it no matter
what
before chickens I don't believe in
checking stuff I'd rather have a hater
correct you leave in the comments on how
I'm stupid it's Mario Luigi
hi Reggie no I'll take Lawrence what's
happening Reggie
I don't know what we're watching this is
ridiculous that I love it
yeah that's it's Reggie a water
this is actually really no really yeah
I'm sure supposed to be funny in some
way but I'm digging the hell of it okay
oh now we smash there we go yeah there
we go
[Music]
who are you get these are the myse
that's best yeah
oh the Me's can fight each other who can
fight with me
yes found in this there we go
[Music]
[Music]
he just murdered him but you could have
to team up oh yeah know that look it
looks awesome dude I'm just excited
about the fact that I could I could be
in the game you could be in the game you
you this is cool man's better than the
Sims it's a lot better than no that
looks sweet yeah I'm excited to get that
game i [ __ ] I mean all these game
systems man I'm gonna be so poor yeah I
hope they were like we slaughtered
everyone with our we and then they came
back my network and now we've got Wii U
and no one really cares though no
everyone has an iPad already so it's
kind of silly to also then get a console
that comes with its own iPad essentially
yeah I mean don't get me wrong I
freaking love the tenant with all my
heart one thing they didn't show in this
one is that there's actually when you
create a me character you have three
different classes there's the brawler
which punches and stuff there's a swords
sword fighter and then there's another
class the shooter which is essentially a
Samus like character cool yeah Raggedy
rad rad hashtag knowledge what is the do
we know the life of character um Jesus
Christ yes
Wolverine confirmed Katniss Everdeen
confirmed just those three those three
and there's some secret characters Ryan
Gosling and Rev confirmed Ron Burgundy
confirmed and then there's another
trailer the pac-man one pac-man
this may contain content appropriate for
children that's not good like newsy
nudity in the first Super Smash Brothers
game guys I'm excited
well you know they added Solid Snake
last time man you got it you gotta sell
units in it
there's one way sell units tits in Smash
bro why not mix it's all about the nips
Samm is Samm is nips Charlie's eating in
an hour can we react to that links one
of my favorite the blasts oh yeah
you can play as the Sun I'm so stupid I
did not realize that this was you could
actually play as pac-man pac-man maybe
get pretty bad fruit it's a pretty
[ __ ] see that you can play as pac-man
that's pretty cool this is so [ __ ] me
Oh neat it's like old-school style all
right
yeah I'm pretty sold on this game yeah
after two trailers guys people ready for
this game my channel reconfirmed I don't
really know the purpose that other than
educating people about the past but sure
yeah that was cool that was neat I want
this game now get on dan you have a
gaming channel is there a way you could
hook me up with the game early sure I'm
good friends with all of Nintendo hello
a Nintendo we need smash get me all
right guys oh we've been talking for a
while now so I'm just gonna say this if
you're new to the channel mm-hmm there's
this button up here it says subscribe it
does and I keep forgetting to mention
this he has his own channel to click
here to subscribe to his channel yeah
I'm the parrot man they should do like a
comic book version of Super Smash
Brothers Batman there was kind of with
injustice gods among us which was a DC
fighting game but ya know she'd just be
like super smash brothers novo with
Batman there's Batman should just be in
the new smash bros just saying Batman
should be in the next day brought Solid
Snake and why can't they bring Batman
there's time mmm it's not too late
Nintendo what's a few more algorithms
come on Bo character modeling whatever
tech psycho
so you said I want a shout out or else
dot dot dot dot don't God don't mm
that's cool cuz he's like he's like
making a mysterious or she uh making it
mysterious like you don't know it's
open-ended it's like I'm not that you're
like you're gonna get tased
it could be worse or it could be not as
bad hmm your life is a soap opera you
really really interesting to be here
along for the ride I just want to know
what you're gonna do I mean what if I
like it
what if it turns me off lead to more
shadows I guess it would behoove it
wasn't yeah it wouldn't move me I know
what that word means
March Stephen he said thank you for
doing your videos first thing I do when
I jump on YouTube is check to see if you
have new videos up keep up the awesome
work
thanks Mark Stevens that is too kind you
should be killed
that's a drastic jump from thinking hey
guys this is not working out for my show
I can do whatever the [ __ ] I want to my
fans Mark Stephens watching us right now
like oh I got a shot did he just call
from my yeah for my death he's running
over he's locking his doors
I offer $1,000 to the man who brings me
mark Lehman oh no no do that I don't
know no kind of money I will not pay you
it anyway man yeah sorry
hi I know people want more from shout
outs like love but I don't know I was
just kind of into our shadow
I'm in a dark mood today Jong Lee he
wanted me to say I'm his friend so he
can feel popular you're my friend John
Lee my best friend I like when people do
the little emoticons but with too many
mouths like some kind of mutant happy
face he's Asian he's Asian observe it
mm-hmm
I like Asian people you do oh you're a
woman do ya know the first thing you
that's me to run you you introduced me
to Dan right now and you didn't tell me
what his nationality is now first time
truth is I don't [ __ ] know
my marriage yeah you got it
no [ __ ] you totally like normally this
would have been like dude okay he he's
Irish isn't that awesome and then I'm
like I guess yeah what are you Irish
German French Canadian matter no I don't
have anything
they're super I don't know [ __ ] about
Canadians [ __ ] I just hope John Lee
feels like I'm his friend I mean you
should probably hang out I love that one